what happens if you combine a truck with
a fun welcome to [ __ ] this is the
game about [ __ ] trucks this game is
made by Swedish people so you know it's
advanced perfect technology as you can
so clearly see in front of you so the
game is a pretty simple Oh God it's
about jumping on trucks remember that
scene from neo sorry the second Matrix
movie that was really weird to look at
they made that into a game so here I go
Jesus Christ I can jump so much Paul but
I can fail very easily too I feel like
I'm a bunny I feel like I'm the chosen
one so the game starts off pretty simple
[Music]
let's take that back the game starts I
got the slow motion as well I forgot
about that
well that's awesome so it's gonna be
super cool later trucks gonna be
everywhere oh my god it's gonna be crazy
look at that [ __ ] you see Swedish people
we know how to make games I've never
made a game in my entire life but we
know how to make games I have nothing to
do with this game at it whatsoever but
we know how to make games okay level 5
baby I'm gonna go through the hole yes I
don't even feel like making a sex joke
there the [ __ ] writes itself okay it's a
very tight corridor chronic breeze
through it but luckily we're small and
tiny to get through and we did it ah
hold this [ __ ] there's a lot of rocks oh
oh
holy moly moly macaroni [ __ ] Jesus
Christ oh my god don't [ __ ] that down oh
no what are those things in the middle
like creams why would they Oh God
got a little opera singing there for a
second you're welcome oh [ __ ] oh oh
we're going for it 360 are you kidding
me
steady steady steady as we go oh god
there's other people coming in the
opposite direction does anyone know how
to drive in this game I think that would
be great
I've got it we're not gonna know [ __ ]
okay here we go oh this is cool like
trees and [ __ ] I love trees nailing this
[ __ ] this is easy that all you got game
what the [ __ ] oh god there's a lot of
trucks here a lot of trucks here the
[ __ ] are those oh oh what oh God
oh good [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] awesome
oh yeah that was like epic scene from my
epic movie getting way more difficult
good thing I'm a pro great gamer dreamer
- [ __ ] okay ah [ __ ] [ __ ] that duck good
yeah all that sound effect it helps
don't worry about it
alright it's so intense hey I'm sweating
while playing this game I'm disgusted by
myself
that's how much I'm into this day
I am disgusted but there's no time for
discussion whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh
Spyder [ __ ] hmm pani feat Don okay I'm
getting the hang of this I feel like I'm
finally good at games
this could be my one pro title that I I
quit my youtube career but just become a
pro it look at this 360 oh my god oh my
god it's so satisfying to just jump on
this [ __ ] it's like the only game that
going on a [ __ ] is cool so obviously
this is an early version of the game but
it's it's fun to play if you want to
check out I guess
feel free to quote me on that Swedish
Swedish guys I made this game
PewDiePie it's fun to play I guess now
one more epic stunts and [ __ ] when I
jump in the air
that'd be awesome all right did I do it
yeah here we go here we go okay what do
I do what do I do
I'll go back plan B
huh huh yeah yeah that's right
wow that's uh oh hey are you doing up
there oh no what are you going buddy
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] suicidal cluster drugs that's
what happens when they got their [ __ ]
they have no more reason to live okay
let's stay here oh this is awesome okay
all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this one's going
south hey I'm still in it to win it
yeah sayonara [ __ ] ash I'm gonna go in
this one this is faster I'm like
prepubescent Mario goddamnit don't hit
that yeah let's watch pity pile jump on
trucks for an hour yeah let it all be
fun great idea of a video Pierce my arm
just hurts from all this shift and W
clicking my life is so hard people don't
realize I'm gonna insurance my hand okay
here we go yes Oh oh my god
no we're not giving up no good oh oh oh
oh
[Music]
god [ __ ] damnit piece of [ __ ] that
was so epic
oh my god this is so cool oh my god what
if [ __ ] the [ __ ] eye microphone is
happening I'm just gonna jump I'm just
gonna [ __ ] jump
holy [ __ ] that is the coolest [ __ ]
thing I've ever seen in my life oh my
god
where do I go oh the gold was there and
I [ __ ] it up jab na god damn that was
so cool that was like straight out of an
action movie okay we got here we go here
we go oh he's beginning to
Oh mother [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
it's basically trucks [ __ ] I made a
lot more sense than I intended it to be
but if you enjoyed please do leave a
like I really appreciate it let me know
if you want to put blame or check this
game out I'll leave a link through
description Swedish quality products and
as always stay awesome em you [ __ ]